okay [ __ ] at your boy cyka [ __ ]
babble babies and we are continuing the
game the last of us are kind of a pace
okay yellow Lanka now I got hit in the
head by a woman on this day today 00 lat
on my head but I'm gonna try get this
game going for you you know what I'm
saying to him this loading screen if I
get along motherfuckas ah [ __ ] yeah why
do I so hope you all day was good while
this thing's [ __ ] loaded Oh starting
it's starting starting okay so what
happened last thing we heard week when
they want to use her to like make a
vaccine but I'm like [ __ ] it like you
know that [ __ ] hurt over and over again
um see here okay that's this I can get
down
yeah yeah I guess you know yep they are
so damn Tala is correct bomb the hell
are the surrounding areas to the
quarantine zones hoping to kill him gosh
you hear that yeah sounding pretty far
away though good good I don't know what
the [ __ ] penalize us come on okay good
good good God you know I for some reason
I love ya [ __ ] from a height like
not like being up high cheating toilet
I'm talking about like well there's the
Capitol building is it there oh yeah
rallies nice now I think so uh I like
like spreading my cheeks in like late
fall the shed I don't know something
about that just like excites me you know
okay over here so I up that way ok ok ok
I guess there is goodness I shuttin
email there's gonna be some [ __ ] going
on in here hey Jess I've got bodies
pretty fresh
that might be let's not stick around
just safe nobody really knows nobody up
I'll take this thank ya thank ya thank
ya holy [ __ ] okay guess you're gonna huh
hello sir take this I'll take this I
don't need up [ __ ] yeah why not grade I
got a contact is there a negative
contact and they come kak multiple
infected contacts Winnie back didn't
happen so these guys died waiting for
backup geez el last batch it looks like
my second line actually I'll do to you
heck yeah sort of yeah they see using so
yeah that's like that if you hear when
clicking you gotta hide that's how they
spot you sucking gross why would why
would I go in there that's where the
calf ucking guy was [ __ ] mice that's
the only thing worse than zombies is
[ __ ] nice
the bill it goes like it's about to fall
apart that's like this I can't I yeah
okay [ __ ] okay Walt rude you watch
your head [ __ ] anything get here and
now it's actually not solly cold a
[ __ ] building where I was coming down
shove it or make this [ __ ] and okay
get some buckets on this can i make any
more chefs ah [ __ ] i was had a lot of
[ __ ] oh I can I feel the whole thing run
whale [ __ ] what is that picture out
disgusting I don't have anything of it
name is yeah oh yeah let any tea shops
oh damn it one uh-huh that's like first
out and secure supplies searches as yeah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was real welcome to the
bart a [ __ ] I've come to that part did
she get something at yourself up you
should thank you thank you
I love running around with the brick
okay that's written i could shift on my
doors go [ __ ] this is the right place to
pay [ __ ] this is the right
place to pay that is this yeah
yes they're just sucking down a mess
holy [ __ ] out here they scare the [ __ ]
at me I thought that was [ __ ] that
boy Oh what the [ __ ] up there huh I
really look dad there's a way through
[ __ ] no one's gonna mention that [ __ ]
its dangling right there anyone will see
that shut okay it's clear all right all
right kid you're up yeah why they take
[ __ ] forever anything over here what
up [ __ ]
okay come on back gamer hand I'll give
you more than my hand I'll give me my
hat let's go that s how it started new
civilization with you if you know what
I'm ciphers [ __ ] go go oh oh hello sir
[ __ ] gross I got cut wait i thought
they can't like see you we can't see
mirror now this [ __ ] can't see me
I grab I'm gonna grab it
that's a [ __ ] grass
shadow Jenna he's a ship though again
I'm explore this place now oh hello my
name's Madonna I come from my future
here crackin what is this
that's over here you want me eat out of
the eight out of 12 balls that what I
gotta do for views huh is that what you
guys want me to eat a little apple cuz
I'll do it I'll [ __ ] do it anything
for use okay okay okay
ah yes I like it better here I think
that's it hell are you okay [ __ ] my
pants okay okay let's go anything four
ships anything four ships now what the
[ __ ] oh I get it over it you'll be
second give me a second you know your
real reason I did this you go ladies the
show that i have the strongest sex drive
the strongest by far how do I look it
okay Jesus okay here we go shet inside
you got duck day should we go back up no
uh hello you [ __ ] zenus yet or is he
here let's go [ __ ] just don't look down
they call a babysitter [ __ ] go go yes
I'm very serious let's go yes
ok
hello Jessica yeah there's a city right
thing one would tell this is my latest
Degrassi could be like Georgia okay we
got away from that camp cat not grab
[ __ ] here
[ __ ] is this a revolver okay oh [ __ ]
sorry nine millimeter holy [ __ ] can they
get up here [ __ ] I gotta go down there I
got idea
come on I know you had that [ __ ] I know
you had that is there like no one else
there can i I really don't want a
[ __ ] jump down there sanna when I
could shoot from here
when you say I guess posli one right
there can't see them wow this game is
[ __ ] clever they will not let me
shoot one you just check real quick yeah
[ __ ] it I gotta go down there no
sucking [ __ ]
Jesus get this [ __ ] right here okay
well now that's over with spider-sense
okay get oh [ __ ] anything over there now
[ __ ]
there's a lot of [ __ ] guys here yet
okay well this guy's coming this way
right
holy [ __ ] like I see me
wow this is actually a scary oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] all this [ __ ] is clicking that
[ __ ] is clicking all over the place
need to get this [ __ ] yep [ __ ] he's
taking too long it's taken away too long
[ __ ] a at least they can't like see
their buddies and like know something
that happened you know what cuz I'm
[ __ ] blind shut oh [ __ ] come on stop
where you going don't go sir can't [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] and horrify okay if one's a
little far now let me take this [ __ ] ok
I love you a classic Bill Cosby
impression watch is ready this is how
the Bill Cosby impression works you make
a noise and then when you come
[ __ ] I got one ship left okay I'm just
gonna get him when he chose her out
again
no one else singing on behind me right
okay I'll get this [ __ ] now get this
[ __ ] come on oh oh [ __ ]
shippy one more there we go
where is he
okay i don't see shouts there we go eat
that we got it yeah yeah don't mention I
don't mention get out of here anything
good here what is that a prick is this
candy take it okay
the [ __ ] is this I'll take this thank
you very much match come on open for
daddy okay Carrie hair yay shud i can't
let go tesco now okay guess we're all
right hold on yeah take your time rich
yes thank ya thank ya alright so here
take on these bottles i'll take on many
smiles doing alright Oh anything over
here extraordinary Oh a bunch of good
crafting materials just what i like to
say that God get mama girl sucking just
keep moving it was good to it [ __ ]
[ __ ] her running yet this game seems
like it's very like okay around enemies
and you're safe I don't think isn't
really gonna be struggling but there is
you know I take out mine on pace you
know take it I nine pace and I keep
going and it says I don't know what it
is but I'll take it
come on a ship uh-huh you're pairing
like pigeons and they sound like that
creatures after we get back now you want
to settle down at such a sign he won't
take it easy hey you're the one always
going on and you always brushed me off
hey let that [ __ ] am I just sewing and
shed don't believe it when I see what's
going on here Oh guess I'll let her just
swimming in yet
oh god I bathe in this bathing
Thank in this game kind of forces me
together right direction dang what are
also i'm going to [ __ ] and suck up and
i'm going our way
thank god yes down here oh [ __ ] ok I'll
does intently look at his sleeve
firefall these guys aren't doing well in
or out of the city thank God look is
that noise
no I need like a brick that right
I'll shut okay um [ __ ] Harry Lotus [ __ ]
what's his [ __ ] down okay I'll take
this paper I'm gonna be that [ __ ] who
got time to review [ __ ] these days we're
trying to make it there here a lot okay
that girl who their system hey Joel you
take point i watch the rear no matter
what you stood right on his heels now
Stacia you're hot as [ __ ] I can't take
that thank you yeah take some on this
baby
oh yeah it's a nice house janes nice
[ __ ]
a lot of clicking in here
oh oh it looks like that's sick to me
all right okay just [ __ ] always in my
time let the Derek Bell see with the
eyes when you get close tonight put my
stuff at three 4378 come on come on this
is the book just kind of getting scary
got it Matt
you
okay whoa did you see that
no shot he is clicking like a
[ __ ] I gotta set this [ __ ] far
away yeah sure
Oh
oh [ __ ] hey violet oh [ __ ] [ __ ] my
[ __ ] [ __ ] my [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
these guys okay get get get hurt her
okay we had the [ __ ] fight I'm going
first pitches on the man oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ] get up here she says yeah
thanks to make everyone okay yes let's
move you guys are pretty good at this
stuff it's cold luck and it is gonna run
out okay we're gonna we're gonna end
this right here thanks for watching
[ __ ] okay and hopefully see y'all
next episode day kicks out for her Amish
Oh